we have
just only the flame covering it with
either the patch please avert my eyes
in the Japanese text the hooded woman
defers to the crow like creature as
father but she means it in a religious
sense not a paternal one so it's more
like the word Reverend Godfather or
perhaps most accurately all father and
if you're invested in the law of these
games then you already know this is all
father Lloyd Lloyd was said to be the
uncle to Lord Gwyn and he was a focus of
worship within the way of white which
was this holy Covenant devoted to the
gods and to the maintenance of the
bonfires and in particular Lloyd was
known for his cleric Knights and he was
praised for their undead hunts which
were successful partly because of
Lloyd's talismans which were these
throne items that block Undead recovery
via Estes and in the earlier footage we
saw Lloyd slaying himself over a Lourdes
vessel full of this liquid fire which is
like Estes really so this creature being
Lloyd is a certainty to me most notably
Lloyd is no longer a proud man like he's
described previously in fact in the
current age of Dark Souls 3 all father
Lloyd is described as being long
forgotten by the way of white and the
clerics of Kareem stands strong in their
assertion that Lloyd was always a
derivative fraud with his all-father
title self proclaimed it makes sense
then that he should appear in the world
of the forlorn the unwanted and the
exiled the painted world of REM and
Miyazaki has confirmed that the DLC
takes place in the painted world al be
it a different painted world there's
this article from polygon that I'm going
to talk about which mentions quite a few
things that you wouldn't have caught if
you just watched the trailer
so first Miyazaki says that he's aiming
for a more gothic flavor in not just
this DLC but the next DLC as well
they're linked in this sense the two
DLCs and they're said to be somewhat you
from the base game and IGN Japan reports
that the focus is on the second DLC to
complete and finish the story there will
be two new bosses and we've actually
seen all elements of both of the fights
in what is presumably the main boss
fight the female character clearly
serves as phase one displaying this
dominance over the tied up all-father as
to the woman's identity she's actually
been mentioned in game already the core
vien great scythe reads the mistress of
the painted world is said to wield a
great scythe herself and we always
assumed that this was referring to
Priscilla of Dark Souls 1 but since the
word mistress actually means a woman in
position of authority or control it's
clearly in my opinion referring to this
woman someone with a thematic connection
to Priscilla with the core viens and
with the way of white also perhaps this
woman is Lloyd's apostle mentioned in
the white sands ring description perhaps
she's Gertrude a woman described as a
heretic which might explain the source
of the heretical stories the winged core
viens tell or throughout the land or
perhaps she's as yet unnamed I read that
there were a lot of people crying velka
as soon as they saw her and honestly I'd
be a bit disappointed if this was Velka
I don't envision Velka this god that the
other gods and Lords fear I don't
envision her as a simple humanoid being
to be honest the other boss fight starts
with a human duel as well with the wolf
joining the fight after the defender
falls according to polygon but
interestingly in the trailer we don't
see the wolf join the fight after the
death of the human we see him join
immediately after this shield bash so
why is that why is there a discrepancy
in the information here my best guess is
that the flash of the wolf's face here
when you get shield bashed might trigger
the wolf's appearance
in the fight early if you get caught by
it and considering that this human enemy
is so oddly dressed and actually a
player like NPC do you think this could
be a sign that this is an actual player
like in the mirror night fight from Dark
Souls 2 for example I hope so that was
one of the best encounters in Dark Souls
2 and I love the way the wolf fights I
just have to say that it's so
reminiscent of SIF and I do believe it
is SIF or at least it's an incarnation
of him just like Osiris was an
incarnation of safe for example the
visual details are identical his face
and his eyes are exactly the same I
can't wait to find out more about why he
is here and I do hope they really
fleshed out this part of the story
because they run the risk of this just
being a shallow throwback if they don't
flesh it out anyway my favorite move of
his is this one where he misses you to
kick up all the snow and then he attacks
you from within the mist it's this
fighting style that's consistent with
how the wolves are described in game as
enemies how they can found their prey
when they fight and regularly sized
wolves are enemies in the DLC too though
we only see one in the trailer he's
hidden at the back here polygon
describes them as devious they say they
watch from a distance and they maintain
that distance until the entire pack is
gathered and only then will they all
attack at once and I like that I think
it's really important for the designers
of this DLC to keep the player's mind
occupied with visual elements like the
Wolves constantly threatening you that's
a great one because in open level design
like this it's easy to get a bit bored
because you don't quite need the same
awareness you do when you're traversing
a complex dungeon and it's traps other
enemies include these tree women which
I'm guessing are which trees as the
witch tree stave item description says
that their customary in the far north
and we know that the north is a cold
place from the
northern said and there are enemies
wearing very northern set esque armor
anyway regardless of what they're called
these long-limbed trees will grab at you
if you come too close and they hurl orbs
of flame at you if you stray too far the
other main enemy in this area are the
hollow warriors with the pointed Helms
and at first I thought these might be
members of ferren's undead legion as the
pointed steel helm is described as a
distinct symbol of theirs plus it makes
some sense for them to be here because
SIF is here as well and the Great Wolf
and it's blood is an object of their
worship so if they are warriors of
Ferren perhaps that explains why the
warrior with SIF has a sorceress stuff
upon his or her hip because Ferren were
known for the sorceries they develop as
well however the sorceress staff is
something given to sorcerers of the vin
hime dragon school and looking a bit
closer the pointed Helms on the Warriors
actually look visually a bit more like
the northern helm though admittedly they
are taller and more narrow than that
helm plus many of these enemies use
shields which the undead Legion aren't
known for my second best guess is that
they're the cleric Knights of Lloyd
they're straight swords have only a
slight hint of a cross guard just like
the sword upon Lloyd's sword ring their
shields have the same shape as the
shield upon Lloyd's shield ring as well
and their affinity with fire might make
them related to Lloyd who we're certain
is at the end of the dlc but let's move
on polygons states there will be four
new spells four full new armor sets and
15 new weapons the most interesting of
which to me is this spear which has a
weapon art whereby you can throw the
spear as a javelin and then magically
have it reappear back in your hand
another interesting thing is the short
Gladius like sword and the shield that
the wolf's companion uses this stance he
or she is in is totally unique and I
wonder if it's a quality of the shield
or the sword or both so yeah that pretty
much wraps things up subscribe for more
Asha's content and please comment below
if you think that there's something I
missed because I'd love to read it and
so what others we usually get some
really good discussions going on down
there I think my comments section is one
of the best and in the spirit of trying
to shout out someone every video I'd
love to direct you to a growing channel
named the ashen hollow Jake has been
doing a great job breaking down some of
the more specific questions of the
series and he has a particularly good
couple of videos on velka and his
theories surrounding her so let's see if
they get proven right or wrong in the
coming months thanks for watching again
and special thanks to patrons I'll see
you next week
you
[Music]
you